in canada kids are ending their in-class
school year but here when russia invaded
in february thousands of students left
with their parents for other countries
those who remained went online if they
could not ideal schools here couldn't
operate kids couldn't learn in
classrooms anymore
here's the obvious reason many schools
like this one on the edge of kharkiv
were attacked by russian rockets this
school was severely damaged in early
april and the area where it's situated
in is one of the most dangerous areas of
the city because of the threat of more
attacks
saying we're going into the school right
now that's now being used as a shelter
it can't be used as a school
david
[Music]
the school's director alexander grayanik
gives global news a tour and we're
conscious of the time because we hear
artillery fire in the distance
[Music]
in the basement we meet irina are you
afraid when you hear those sounds
certainly certainly and all of us
i'm afraid
but is it preferable to be here than
back where you live yes you're right
irina and some others shelter below
ground four months after the war began
she's familiar with this school i have
been working there for 40 years
i know this school the director takes us
from room to room one of the classrooms
hit hardest was this one where they
taught russian literature among other
subjects the rockets left gaping holes
in walls there's metal and glass
everywhere but incredibly a room
untouched by the bombardment was this
room a space entirely set aside with
artifacts depicting ukrainian culture
every item was left undisturbed
getting students back to this school
will be a difficult feat there could be
no rebuilding while the russian attack
threats continue what do you hope
happens next year for the next school
year
we can't hope we wait
we wait we don't know
i would hope
and for school age children offer the
summer break just like canadian kids
that leaves a lot of uncertainty about
what's next in the fall sean o'shea
global news in eastern ukraine